all right
so hello everybody
hope everybody is doing well
um
so today is the 23rd we just found out
that uh
for those who don't follow canadian
politics and i don't um
i don't blame you if you don't but a lot
of people are even people that aren't in
canada so our prime minister
enacted what's called the emergency act
which is actually
something it's actually something which
replaced what's called the war measures
act
and the reason why the war majors act
was
was removed and changed had something to
do with
with justin trudeau's father who was the
prime minister in the
in the in the 70s
enacting it himself and causing a lot of
controversy for the way wayne which was
enacted the way in which people were
arrested without a reason and held and
stuff so they changed it and called the
emergencies act and trudeau used it
which means it gave him unlimited
power
marshall type power
and he started freezing people's bank
accounts
and uh saying he was going to increase
it going to make it longer and
everything and then today he decided to
to back away and
to
to to drop it so you know
yeah it's pretty crazy everything's
pretty crazy that's going on and so it's
so weird because
you know
you guys have been following me for a
while
since i pretty much i've been online
i've been telling people
that this is coming
and that you know that our societies are
going to move towards more authoritarian
uh structures and more authoritarian
let's say impetus and uh now that it's
happening i can't seem to deal with it
very well
the morning that that justin trudeau
announced the emergency uh measures act
it's like i literally threw my back out
and i wasn't doing anything i'm just
kind of hanging around sitting at my
computer and then my back went out it's
like man
all right i need to just get my act
together
and so uh so all right
so yeah it's good to see jacob in the
chat i haven't seen you there for a
while
jacobus rudeness and lefair i see in the
chat
um so anyways it's good to see
people around it's it's good to be able
to get involved more in the chat the way
that we're doing it now so um
so a few announcements
for those that are following the gods
dog stuff it's uh if you could see
my headache i wish you could see my
headache it is such a it has been such a
pain
uh for so many reasons that i won't go
into but um i'm still just plowing ahead
and trying to to get this
to happen it's gonna happen no matter
what but it's just the speed at which
things are crawling i feel like
i don't know if it's because covet is
damaged our entire
system so badly that nobody seems to be
able to do anything at any normal pace
but uh whatever it is very frustrating
so don't worry i haven't forgotten
anybody who uh who supported gus dog i'm
still
still working tirelessly in making
everything come together um
interesting announcement is i in theory
unless
unless things change which is possible
with all the crazy politics going on
here but unless something changes i am
going to be
on stage with jordan peterson in
montreal on may 23rd at plaza desar
which is which is one of the big arenas
the big
kind of theaters here in montreal and so
that's pretty exciting i don't even know
what we're going to talk about yet but
it's uh it's all getting set up as
as i speak to you so that's pretty cool
i haven't seen jordan since 2017 in
person so that's going to be interesting
to see him again
looking definitely looking forward to
that
and all right so last announcement is
as you know the way we're doing it is
that people who support me on patreon at
10 or more
can ask questions in advance and someone
goes through the questions and kind of
filters them
and it's important that you not hand in
your questions the last day because the
person who is going through the
questions will already probably have
done the sifting just because we don't
want to do it at the very last minute
and so please try to get your questions
in
please i mean if you want your questions
to be looked at you want you have to
have them
uh you have to have them put it two
people are going through the questions
brad i'm happy to know that i thought it
was just one person so uh
so the people that are going through the
questions um
they uh
they need at least they they can't do it
they're not gonna do it last minute so
just make sure you get your questions in
before and the questions are gone
through depending on if it's something
that's been asked many many times or if
it's something that's confusing or
something that is this is kind of off
color and so though that's how there are
different ways in which the questions
are chosen so bring them back to a
reasonable level and the other thing you
can do if you support me
uh everybody that supports me on patreon
you know from like two dollars up or
whatever can come live on the chat and
now that we have less people i will
definitely be engaging with people in
the in the chat so uh so that's how
we're doing it
all right so here we go with the uh the
questions
all right and so i'm starting with the
website
so gideon you says
hi uh hi jonathan so my question is what
is the symbolism of snakes or serpents
as we see them shedding their skin all
at once whereas basically every every
other animal sheds its outer layer of
death much more gradually
and
so i think the way to understand that is
it's related to the idea that the snake
represents something well two things
something like
change
and then something like the remainder
and so
interestingly enough if you if you watch
that movie um
noah by uh
aronofsky
which is kind of half it's kind of 50
50. a lot of it is weird some of it is
interesting but anyways in that movie
the garments of skin that adam that adam
and eve get and they get kind of
transmitted down interestingly enough
very similar to the to our our our comic
book we had written it before
aronofsky's noah came out but they had
the same idea of having like this notion
the garments of skin are kind of
transmitted down the uh the generations
but in their case it's a snakeskin which
is the garments of skin that they kind
of received it seems from from god so
that's super interesting um and so
that's why the the snake is
the unit it's the thing in the garden
which is
um you could say
that's inside but is not completely of
the inside that comes from the outside
or is related to the outside of the
garden but is what is inside and that is
that
it is the variable which brings about
change you know that's how you
experience it in life in general
something comes from the something
unexpected something not part of the
system manifests itself and then you
have to deal with it and the way you
deal with it will
will manifest uh a change and so
all right hi jonathan as we exist in a
largely digital age surrounded by
technology powered and run by
electricity can you comment on the
symbolism of electricity
and on a related image lightning thank
so much for all you do
and so
i haven't thought about this a lot to be
honest but
the way that we experience electricity
at least you know as as in our houses
and in the wires and everything
it has something to do with power
i mean i'm saying that if you're like
well yeah no
so it's a it's an aspect of power and so
a lot of
our society is obsessed with power that
is it is obsessed with the capacity to
do more
and that's what electricity provides
it provides the the the capacity to do
more
and so that's mostly the power let's say
the symbolism that it has in our lives
but lightning is different although you
know we lightning is
is electricity but the lightning is
really is a kind of pointing from heaven
it's
it really is like you know you know they
made right zeus with the lightning bolts
throwing lightning bolts down to people
that's pretty much what lightning is
it's like the finger of god coming down
and touching
and
so
there there are some
traditions in different countries where
the idea that if you died for example if
you died by a lightning strike that it
meant
that it it it meant that maybe you were
actually a saint
uh because it was like god pointing you
from above like
um
and
lisa barrett thinks it's funny
she says that's why we call it power
it's like yeah we call it power
uh all right yeah and then
brad says power
yeah
so so but that's that's the difference
between lightning it's like light coming
from above and hitting the ground and
there's a fire coming from above
heavenly fire is what lightning is
related to
so uh so it'd be interesting to think
about the relationship between the
lightning which comes
symbolically the lightning which comes
down from above and then the the
electricity that's in our
our wires
but um i'd have to think about that
i feel like that's something that meteor
would have really good insight in on
yeah
all right josh the mover says it seems
that as time rolls on there are less and
less christians of great ascetic rigor
this is obviously bound up with the
materialism of the present age but is it
possible that the early church produced
far more impressive saints by virtue of
her
chronological proximity to christ
earthly sojourn i think of how the holy
fire doesn't burn believers but only for
about the first 15 minutes thank you
yeah
definitely
i mean i think that there's a sense in
which
there's a sense in which there's a kind
of decline in christianity
from the time of christ until today i
think that's not too controversial to
say that you get that you read that even
in in some of the monks and some of the
aesthetic writings where they they tend
to talk about
the difference between them and those
that came before them and how you know
even if it for us it's before
they had a sense that you know they were
less than the first christians or the
early christians and the saints that
came before them and so there's
definitely something of that going on
like a kind of general sacrifice of of
quality for quantity something like that
so david flores says what is the
symbolic significance of the ear and big
toe
huh i'm specifically thinking about the
ritual in which moses smeared blood
on these body parts of aaron and his
sons
man
i did not remember that tax at all and
so it's like for me it's as if it's the
first time i read this
i'd i feel like i would i might misstep
but it it seems have something to do
with extremes for sure the ears have
something to do with extremes because
their ears are shaped like shells
and they're there's something of a shell
let's say
and a a shell also in the sense of a
something which receives the the sound
um and also ears are
kind of like the extremities of our of
our heads
so
and then the toes maybe would be like so
would be something like covering the
blood on both extremities like extremity
above and extremity below but why the
big toe of all toes
not sure
man
yeah that's a tough one
all right douglas matthew says hello it
seems many current events over the past
couple years have some kind of
connection to the idea of congestion
constriction
etc uh respiratory infections floyd's
death that the ever given jammed in the
canal
clot shots the freedom convoy
i have an intuition that as society
devolves the coming coagulation is
manifest manifesting itself in the
background do you think
i am on to something
or is something else going on here
no for sure i think i think you've got a
you've got you've got uh it right
um
and it's like a it's something which
there's a weird contradictory
there's this weird contradictory thing
happening
uh and that happened especially at the
time of floyd's death which was such a
strange
event because
it was very strange that that george
floyd seemed to die from uh in
incapacity to breathe or at least he he
seemed to express that in capacity to
breathe you see it in the video even
before
even before the policeman it puts him on
the ground that he that he seems to be
experiencing an incapacity to breathe
and that that that the whole i can't
breathe thing became like a
became like a symbol for the for this
idea of the system which clamps down in
terms of racism and everything but
simultaneously the system was clamping
down in terms of mask and everybody was
forced to wear masks but there was like
this opposition where both sides
were experiencing this kind of
restriction
um
but for different reasons one it was
more like an actual physical thing and
the other it was more
this sense of the oppressive kind of
institutional racism so it's very
fascinating fascinating it's very
strange to see
that that symbolism seems to be and you
can understand it and especially in
terms of
especially in terms of the the breathing
it's it has to do with the running out
of spirit ultimately is what it has to
do with it has to do with the sense that
we're running out of air running out of
of spirit and then
things are jamming up inside because
we're running out of spirit
and uh and so the idea of the truckers
seemed that seems to be
part of that as well so
yeah
yeah and i hadn't thought about that
that boat that that was clogged up
i mean it's like you can see that it's
basically
the this lack of spirit and then things
here everything getting locked up
you know and the truckers ah that's it's
it's a really good intuition because i
hadn't connected the boat getting
clogged up and then also the freedom
convoy and stuff trying to stop the
transport and borders so
yeah good insight
um
so mark greetings from tbilisi
people talk about individuality unable
to divide but i see no evidence for this
and anyone i've met including myself
we're not individuals if we assume that
christ was an individual then is not
individuality a good thing
to pursue
then
then
if if we assume that christ was an
individual then is not individuality a
good thing to pursue and so i think that
it's important to understand like if you
notice i rarely ever use the word
individual i mean i know that jordan
uses that word a lot and kind of the
idea of individual rights
and at least i think that in christian
terms we tend to talk about persons
and the reason why we talk about persons
in the traditional study of hypostasis
is related to the idea that persons are
united by a nature and persons are not
individual in the absolute sense that is
their communal you could say so our
trinitarian theology
and and the christology
tends to point towards the idea of
something which exists fully like a
person has its own
its own reality its own kind of
ontological
reality but that reality is shared with
others and there's a kind of
interpenetration between persons that
come together and maintain their their
in their separateness but are always
being filled and are feeling others with
their presence you could say and so it's
a different definitely a different
vision
and um
and it's one which in a certain manner
doesn't totally jive with just the idea
of this of the obsession with individual
rights and freedom which we see
in um
in the in some of the enlightenment
project and something like the american
american project as well
so um so i so i would say it's better to
use the word person
it's a much better much better uh term
and it has a richer has a rich history
and a rich connotations that avoid this
idea like you said of inc the individual
as like
isolated or impossible of being divided
so
uh mfp
rysl asks
can you expand on why you think
nominalists ruined everything he said
something in this vein in one of the
interviews we talk about logoy and
categories of chairs and cuffs you've
seen vary in line with nominalism what
until you make a claim and they can make
a jump to the claim that these are all
spiritual beings
is this about nominalist not recognizing
that the various patterns actually act
in the world
and don't just sit quietly in a filing
cabinet
and so
the reason why nominalists
ruined everything they didn't ruin
everything they started something they
were part of i mean it's hard to always
tell exactly when something starts i
mean obviously
there was all this bubbling going on at
the time and so some people pointed back
to aquinas some people pointed back to
augustine and then
some people pointed back to the
beginning of christianity right
depending on on like how
hostile you are to to christianity
itself let's say
but the best way to understand it is
that
what akam did is
in his desire to preserve the
let's say the the holiness of god or
that the separateness of god
what he did is he made god
he removed all the necessities anything
that you could consider and is that
necessary in god so he didn't
in the let's let me start up at the
beginning so in the more traditional way
of understanding christianity let's say
in the in the dionysian way of
understanding christian of god you had a
sense in which god is both
there's an apophatic aspect of god
that god is beyond all name is beyond
all all of everything
but that be
because of that and through that he also
then
fills up the world with his presence
that he he keeps the world going
in so he's both
absolutely transcendent and absolutely
imminent at the same time
that both of those need to coexist in
order for
christianity to be true now
what akam did in my estimation is that
he really wanted to preserve the
transcendence of god the idea that god
can is free right god can do anything
but
in doing that
he made god completely removed from the
world and made the world separate from
god
and then he also
made it ended up making god arbitrary
though i know that's not what he wanted
but it ended up making god something
like arbitrary because
the idea isn't that god can do whatever
he wants like that's not that's not the
way in which freedom was understood by
the by the ancients by people before in
earlier earlier thinkers and so
so by making god completely outside of
the world so completely transcendent
then what he did is he this world became
a kind of thing that had its own rules
and its own causalities that were not
related to god and didn't want to you
didn't want them to be related to god
because you wanted
god to be completely transcendent and
capable of acting on the world but that
the world is separate let's say from god
and then
so it meant that the world not at the
outset but it slowly started to become
more and more arbitrary itself with
arbitrary causation and arbitrary
mechanisms and so if you look at the
notion
of
occam's razor which is that you should
not posit
any more beings that are needed to
in order to
describe a phenomena
and so it's like what is that what does
that mean it means that
you're moving maybe it didn't happen
right away but you're moving towards a
world where you don't have to posit the
reasons for things or the higher aspects
of things in order to describe their
mechanical causes right i can describe
the makeup of a being
without positing
higher higher purposes for that being
and so it ends up being something like
not positive intermediary being not
positing active agents which move down
from the higher spheres up from the
transcended realm down into
the down into the world and those
those higher beings are something like
the fractal pattern that i talk about
they're beings that embed themselves in
each other that
that that are under patrons they have
patrons that act in the world and these
patrons kind of come all the way down
into
into the world so there's everything is
connected every there's an analogy
between
between manifestation between the the
events in the world
and then through all these intermediary
beings whether it's whether it's
whether it's just higher participations
right it's like it's things participate
in higher and higher beings and that's
how things kind of hold together and
then that scales all the way up into
something like the infinite you know
of course there's a jump at the infinite
there's no
there's a jump at some point where it
kind of jumps up into something which is
which is infinite but
nonetheless that that normal
relationship is the one i feel like i'm
not being super clear hopefully
hopefully this is clear
yeah all right sorry guys if that wasn't
clear all right let's just keep going
so i'm not an expert on anomalism also
by the way but i do have a good sense of
what it of what it is and what occam was
was uh declaring so c street soul says
hello jonathan are you familiar enough
with the epic of gilgamesh to elaborate
on the story symbolism if not can you
please explain the predatory
aspect of heaven
yeah i mean gilgamesh is a story about a
tyrannical system that's the story
and so heaven can be predatory in the
moments when systems become tyrannical i
talk about this
i talk it's like a deformation of heaven
it's it's it's when principalities go
off script when they do things on their
own and they they act in pride you could
say
um and so that's definitely the story of
of uh of gilgamesh and so you can
imagine that
gilgamesh
is
a
he's like a nephilim basically he's like
he's this powerful powerful being which
brings about civilization but then
becomes tyrannical in the way that he
imposes it and the way he becomes
tyrannical is that he wants all the
potential
for himself right he wants to take
everybody's wife
that's that's that's this image of the
tyrannical king who wants to you know
establish his kingdom in a way that goes
in every into every detail that he wants
to penetrate every aspect of his kingdom
you know that's what gilgamesh is doing
think about the the image that i talked
about of king saul who tries to pin
david to the wall and so that's what
gilgamesh is trying to do
to his kingdom
but that is an appropriate that's an
inappropriate relationship because
that's why it's like
that's why that's what hierarchy is for
it's like when when systems become
tyrannical what often happens is that
there there's a lack of respect of the
natural hierarchy and so
the person at the top wants to
infiltrate every level of the hierarchy
all the way down whereas a normal way of
doing it is that you have intermediaries
along the hierarchy intermediary
patterns intermediary structure so
if gilgamesh had been a good king he
would have let his aristocracy you know
uh rule the different elements that
they're ruling and he would have left
let the husband
be the husband to their own wives in a
manner that was normal and didn't need
the king to come all the way down to the
bottom in order to fill everything with
himself so that's what gilgamesh is
doing now
the answer to gilgamesh is is enkidu
because enkidu is the margin he's the
wild man he is
he is the power of that which is below
right he's the dragon he's a monster
he's a hybrid he's all these things he's
this he's this uncivilized man
that challenges gilgamesh and reminds
him
that
gilgamesh cannot fully
kind of contain this
and so when enkidu challenges gilgamesh
and tries to stop him if you remember
the story
of course a different version of it but
if you remember the story
gilgamesh is going into the town to take
someone's wife and then enkidu steps in
front of him and prevents him from going
into the door he becomes like a guardian
right he acts as he he's trying also to
reinstate the normal hierarchy
between the levels he's like no you
can't come into this house to take this
woman because you stay up there don't
come all the way down here and it's
interesting because usually we think of
the guardians as acting
the other way like you know we're going
up but no it's he's like cerberus who
says
it's like you know service is at the
gate of of hades and he's like yeah you
may be a king but you're not going down
into hades because it's you stay in your
stay on your side stay in your world so
that's what enkidu is doing but then the
interesting aspect is that yankindu ends
up completing gilgamesh and that when
gilgamesh fights enkidu but then ends up
having a kind of admiration and
compassion
for
for ekidu then they become brothers and
and then they complete each other and uh
and gilgamesh is able to
see his
you could say see that which is he is
lacking or see that potential that he
doesn't have access to
as something which is
which is glorious in a way because it's
it's it's not him but it's also
reminding
him of
of a truth about how reality works and
so
you know and so you see the predatory
aspect of heaven in a lot of stories
like think about when
um
think about when
israel asks for a king and samuel tells
israel
he's like you want a king
if you have a king what is the king is
gonna do he's gonna he's gonna come from
above like a predatory bird and he's
gonna take your sons he's gonna take
your daughters for himself he's gonna
take the best of yours and he's going to
pull it up and so the predatory bird is
the good is a good vision of
in general let's say the the predatory
aspect of heaven so
yeah so hopefully that makes sense
all right so cormac jones says hi
jonathan i'm currently fascinated by the
nico riots in constantinople in 532 the
ones that precipitated emperor justinian
rebuilding hagia sophia do you know
about
them enough offhand to discuss their
symbolism if not perhaps you can invite
dr mario bagos again
to talk about the age of justinian it's
very apocalyptic thank you yeah man
yeah justinian is a fascinating
character just
because think about everything he
accomplished and everything he did
all his amazing successes but also his
tragic failures
uh thinking that he went through a
plague and you know he was basically
fighting barbarians and
stuff it's pretty impressive but i think
in uh
in the case of the nico riots i think
the thing that stands out is of course
theodora's reaction
which is that
you know i talked a bit about the role
of women in christianity about how they
they tend to act
you could say something like they act in
private in a manner which
gives
which opens the door to possibilities
which the man didn't think of and so you
see that that's why there's always women
converting before men in um
for all the emperors and all the kings
basically of europe it's always like a
mother or a sister or a wife that is
converting before the king
and so here you have this this same
image where when
when a justinian
wants to uh to flee the so it's
interesting that first of all it's
interesting that the riots happen at the
games it happens at the at the chariot
races and so
you know it's like it's like here's this
these games here's this kind of
entertainment and then
the factions of the game kind of turn
against the emperor and then and then
decide to uh to attack the the palace
um
and like i said it's interesting
theodora is the one who says you know
justinian is ready to go he's ready to
lead to flee the city and what is it
that theodore says she says something
like the
the purple the purple will make an
excellent burial shroud like the purple
is the of course the color that the
color that all the emperors are allowed
to wear which was this kind of dark kind
of reddish blue uh this kind of purplish
color
and she's basically saying you know
it's like i'm willing to go all the way
with this like i will die here in
constantinople as a queen and not as a
as some fugitive out there and she
basically gives justinian the courage to
uh
to stay and to face the writers um
which you know ended up in a pretty
bloody of course
but uh but yeah so that's what i think
it's pretty interesting definitely an
interesting time
all right so rivo asks let's see if
there are some questions in the chat
here quickly is any question in the chat
or is it just
it's just lisa and brad arguing with
people
all right so let me ask one one one
question so jenna ziki asked
how does how does pedicionary prayer
work
i mean
how does petitionary prayer work it
works just like any petition that you
have
it's hard it's a little hard to
understand for people how it works but
you if you bring it back to the level of
your of the way you understand it it
works similar to that that is
you
let's say you ask
of something and if that something is in
line with the will of that which is
above you
then that thing might be granted it's
also petitionary prayer is also
something like an opening up of a
possibility
which wasn't necessarily visible before
wasn't necessarily
the needs of the people you know they
they act as
questions which are answered from above
and though the world gets filled that
way it's like uh you know a child asks
for
something of his parents
and then the parent will
give or not that thing to the child
and that giving will make
they will make that thing now exist in
the world in the child and so
that's how petition
how that's how petitions work you
the the type of prayer where you ask
is something like
it's something like uh
making it possible making things
possible for god
opening up possibilities and asking god
to manifest himself in those
possibilities
um
that's the best way i can explain it you
know
all right so revo
says hi jonathan
what is the symbolism of christ's
statement that in the world to come none
shall be married or given to marriage as
a romantic person this has always been a
great stumbling block for me i've heard
david c ford argue marriages are eternal
in some sense in the orthodox
understanding but i but still i struggle
to understand why christ would say such
a thing
um
i mean i think that i think it's simply
just because it's supposed to be
something like a return to the garden
it's something
so there's a sense in which
the there for zane gregor nissa and some
other science say maximus they suggest
that the separation of the human into
male and female
was
a provision for the fall
that it was it was like it's not a fall
but it's like it's like god knows the
fall is coming and so he creates this
division the sense would have been that
before that
man and
male and female would have existed
within adam as a kind of balanced
opposite within him and then that become
exteriorized in adam and eve so i think
that that's what's being suggested is
that when
in the next world right in the in the
fullness of things then we will have
that fullness
within us
and that the types of relationships
we will that we have will not be
um will not be complementary in the
sense of opposites
but rather
the like full beings that engage with
each other
in uh
in a different manner
that's the best way that i can kind of
understand that
all right kelly madden says
what is the meaning of the destructions
of the amorites by hail
is it related to being descendants of
giants as they fled before israel
while
they were going down the slope of beth
haron the lord threw down huge stones
from heaven on them as far as asaka
and they died there were more who died
because of the hailstones than the
israelites killed with the sword
interesting i mean i don't know if it
has necessarily something to do with the
fact that they're giants maybe maybe it
definitely has something to do with
with something like the uncut stone
which comes out of the mountain the idea
like a stone which comes from heaven as
something which is
like this
i mean it's like a natural it's
something like an it is like something
like a natural something unexpected
something which
which comes down from above from down
this uncut stone which rolls down the
mountain and crushes the uh
the the statue in the vision of daniel i
think that this symbolism has something
to do
something to do with that
and so
so i mean i think that in general you
also have to kind of understand that
right there's a way in which heaven also
judges and heaven also
stops the can stop the things which are
not according to are not aligned you
could say and so that's why there's fire
that comes down from heaven that's why
there's and i think the stones are
probably similar but i'm i'd be
interesting maybe there is a
relationship between that and uh
and the giants
all right so j grub what is the
symbolism of toys in particular those
that are miniature or real world things
like dolls or tour cars what function do
they serve
i mean
i think they
they just play they just play function
of kind of
training for kids they're a way to train
kids to engage with with the things of
their parents and so
you can imagine that
that kids
have a
so
discovering the meaning of something is
probably the best way to understand it
or discovering the purpose and kind of
moving into purpose and so you just kind
of start on the outside and then you get
fake versions of something and then you
kind of play around with it and then you
get realer versions of it until you
actually have a baby and then when you
have a baby then you've got
the thing and so it's like a training
into
meaning you could say and so you get
used to
to certain things
as a child as a kind of yeah something
which is not
fully purposeful it's not completely
into its purpose
but is still flexible and fluid
just like you as a child are a little
more flexible and fluid and then as you
move into adulthood you kind of solidify
yourself
into into more concrete purposes so i
think that's at least that's the way i
would understand it
all right so a popper what is the
symbolism of oil dark water from deep
beneath the earth being the source of
power of our modern machine-centered
world what does it mean for the machine
to transition
to feeding off the power of the sun
um
yeah for sure the the oil like the that
that oil is super interesting and it's
interesting to listen to like the
narrative about it and the way that
people talk about like what it is
and uh you know what is it that the
theory you know the idea that it's that
oil is
is like the residue of ancient organic
matter which would have been there you
know millions and millions of years ago
and so it really is this idea of like
this ancient organic matter that
has kind of
settled down into the world and it's
like this regidu which is there and then
you use this residue as fuel
to to uh for power right so
it's almost like it really is almost
like a seed that falls into the ground
and then uses the residue as a kind of
power in order to give it its upward
ascent so definitely that's i think it's
pretty
it's very symbolic and it's very uh it's
very symbolic of what of what the modern
world represents um
and then the idea of the machine
transition to feeding off the power of
the sun
i think that for sure
there's something about there's
something about the the solar panels
which are
definitely about capturing like it's
more it's not just it's not just the sun
it's about capturing the sun
and about kind of capturing in these in
in this in this power
structure so
i think it's a little different
it's going to sneeze there
yeah so i think it's it's not that it's
all of the things about power have to do
with with
this idea of capturing and so you can
imagine that
the the symbolism of capturing the sun's
power in a in a battery or capturing it
in a
in you know through a panel of some kind
is very similar to the idea of capturing
electricity as well
and kind of holding it in a way that now
you can use as a form of power
all right so patreon
moving on to patreon all right
all right so elisa asked what is the
symbolism of tails
is it significant that human beings
don't have tails it is very significant
that human beings don't have tails
and so uh
and so yeah mature ah man i wish my two
could tell you about his analysis of the
symbolism of tales he has a really
really good vision of that um
and it has to do with
you could say that human beings are
are one above and are two below
and so there's like it's like a it's
like a pyramid
and that is it is is very important but
animals have a residue you could say
of that structure and that residue
is a tail and so you can imagine that
the tail is like a unity from behind but
it's it's flexible you know it's it's
shifty so it's like it's like a snake
kind of right and so
that's what that's what the tail has to
do with
um
yeah
so that's what a tail is
all right jeremy firth what is the
symbolism of graffiti most of it is
tagging i was here in forbidden places
and it's often coded with obscure fonts
or in-group references in public places
can you talk a bit more about the symbol
of graffiti so
graffiti is definitely a form of
it's definitely a form of participation
that is very low let's say on the scale
of participation in the sense that it's
a form of participation which is
playing on the idea of the fool or the
illicit
it has to do with a gesture it has to do
with the idea that
so so let's say you build up you make a
really nice building and you're like
i've got this right look at how powerful
we are look at how we made this thing
right it's this is the structure that's
holding up our city right these are the
structures that are making the system
work
and uh and then someone all they need to
do is to come with a can of spray paint
and go shh
and but what they're doing it by saying
that is
you can't hold it all together you can't
keep this clean you can't you can't
control everything
and so it's like a challenge
to the control of the system
and so the more the system becomes
so graffiti has always existed it's you
find it in roman times you find it all
in all kinds of moments but
the fact that graffiti becomes almost
like a cultural art form
can only happen in a world that is
extremely
controlling and extremely systematic and
extremely clean and
and and uh you know technical and so you
have these you know you have all these
structures and then someone comes and
just puts their name on there it's like
they they just tag it and it's like like
you said it's you don't you're not even
supposed to really read their name it's
almost like an obscure
you know an obscure kind of
chaotic sign that just shows that that
they that the system is in total so it's
a and that's why it's also like an
affirmation of the individual
and so you always you know when we talk
about individualism you also have to
understand that the individualism is the
balance of
the the tyrannical kind of state system
so the idea of like the rock star that
is like an individual and has his own
style and the artist that has their own
style and you can recognize you can and
you can you can uh you know you know
that it's that person
by the way they look by the way they
dress by the way they they draw by the
by their art that's just a reaction to
the other side which is this extremely
kind of mechanical world in which we
live
and so you can understand then that in a
system that is tyrannical
someone someone to challenge that will
want to
assert their individuality and so a
graffiti artist is something like the
punk rocker right that doesn't want to
follow your rules and
that that will have some idiosyncratic
way of dressing in order to kind of call
attention to themselves in a world
of robots and a world of people that are
all the same
and so but they're both the same they're
both they're both two sides of the same
coin
um
and one is let's say one brings about
the other and so the graffiti artist
will bring about
systems of cleaning systems of control
that are even more radical you know
that'll force the police to criminalize
graffiti because there's so much of it
um or they'll try to capture it and tame
it you know then have walls that are
just for graffiti artists
that kind of stuff um
and so it's a it's a super interesting
it's a super interesting thing
especially like the idea of also
political commentary challenging the um
challenging the the the the the people
in power at the time you think of banksy
or of of john michel basquiat and how he
was also writing these absurdist
kind of statements um
[Music]
yeah so i hope that makes sense
all right so jenna ziki asks
is there a pattern
to who people marry
i've heard arguments against soul mates
you could marry 20 people and be happy
but it seemed circumstances timing grace
at work in each person plays a huge role
it's finding this person a search or is
it a gift
well i would say that they're probably
i would say that you probably end up
being with someone which is
kind of complimentary to you
and i think that that's usually the type
of person you're gonna end up being
attracted to
in the same manner
if
you don't it's going to kind of happen
because you can imagine just
when you have two people
what's going to happen is that the the
one person let's say one of the people
has characteristics and then has lacks
and the other person has characteristics
and lacks and so
it's normal that if two people are
always together and kind of in close
proximity that at some point
this person's
this person's characteristics are going
to try to
the the characteristic that this person
has which compensates or opposes this
person's lacks are going to just kind of
start to manifest more and more
in a good way in the sense it's like oh
great this per you know i married
someone who can do the things that i'm
not good at and that can take care of
the things that i'm not good at but then
that can also flip into the negative
where it's like you know why don't you
ever blah blah blah blah blah i'm the
only one who blah blah blah blah blah
right so so i think that that that's
just like a natural thing that's going
to happen when you're when two people
come together especially because a man
and a woman are already complementary in
their
in their gender then it's going to kind
of happen in the personality but i mean
the idea that like the soulmate stuff um
i think some some people
some people are not meant to to marry
you know as an orthodox christian i
think that that's pretty clear and that
in some ways that's probably the best
the best path if you can do it
so
so yeah you know
but i i do think that for example i'm
sure that people who marry for romantic
reasons
and people who marry in societies that
that have um
let's say arrange marriages
i would i would pretty much bet that on
the whole
there's no difference between
which marriages are successful or not
and uh maybe even
that there are less successful with the
romantic part because
the the romantic marriage which i said
like i married that way you know most of
us married that way
it's it can be a little dangerous
because at first what you see shining in
that other person
and which attracts you to them strongly
really strongly
is that kind of complementary aspect and
then when the that
complementary
flips
and now you see the negative aspects of
that of those very qualities that you
were attracted to it can be harder to
deal with and if you kind of come into
it more
pose like kind of in a posed way where
families are involved and everybody's
kind of involved so it's not as it's not
as radical a shift but i don't know
because i never lived in a society that
has arranged marriages so i don't know
if that's actually true but
for sure i'm looking around and seeing
people married romantically and i'm
seeing the rate of divorce and i'm
thinking
something's wrong let's say about the
way we're doing it now
so christian clais asks uh good evening
jonathan what's the symbolism of simon
simon of serene thank you from korea
and so i think i mentioned this before
and i think that it it really has to do
it has to do with the sense of the
stranger that is kind of participating
in the story so you can imagine you have
the
you have the romans that are bringing
christ along you have also
the let's say the the
the pharisees and the the people the
jews the jews that are responsible that
are more powerful and then you have the
stranger which comes from very far away
uh from
and is
let's say helping christ support the
cross
so think of if you think of the cross as
like the pattern of reality then you
have something
on the edge like an atlas figure
that comes and helps to support it
um
so it has to do
with
how christianity works how it also
extends out into the strange how it
extends to the lost sheep or to that
which is outside you see that in the
story of
of um
the ethiopian eunuch but uh but i think
in here it really has to do with the
idea of of uh carrying like the idea of
the
of the mount or when christ for example
comes into jerusalem on a donkey right i
think that it's mostly some of that
that's going on i've mentioned
i mentioned before that
that
origen and many of the church fathers
interpret the donkey
on which um christ is writing when he
comes into jerusalem as the nations as
the strange nations and you know and
rabbis jewish interpreters also
interpret this prophecy of messiah
writing on the donkey as being related
to that um and so i think that simon and
cyrene is playing kind of is playing
another version of that in the story of
the crucifixion
so anders
vralstadt hi jonathan i'm curious about
the difference between the snake around
the tree center heart and the snake
around the garden outside the garden
robros there are many snake images in
the bible staff of moses snake on pole
dragons how can you know which is
related to which symbolism
um they're all very much related to be
honest
uh
in the sense that so
so right the aeroboros is like a is a
circle and then you see the serpent
eating it its own tail
but
the let's say the best the best way to
understand it is rather to understand
that it's never fully the snake eating
its own tail although that there's
usefulness in that symbolism at that
moment when the beginning and the end
come together that there's a kind of
chaos there's a there's inversion or
there's a confusion in in causality
in the moment where the end of the
beginning appear like when the system
breaks down and a new thing is on the
verge of starting but the best another
way to understand it is as cycles that
go like this
that kind of go up or go or grow down
whatever you however you want to think
of it depending on on the the depending
on the system so it's like cycles that
go like this and so the the
the serpent wrapped around the tree is
similar to the serpent wrapped around
the world it's just at a lower at a more
inside level so one is more microcosmic
and the other is more macrocosmic um and
the different snakes that are on the
different poles all have pretty much the
same symbolism
so
yeah so that's really i think the best
way to understand it
all right matthew asks is there a
hierarchy of symbolism in scripture some
books blossom with symbolism genesis
song of songs while other
not so much paul's epistles appreciate
all you do
i mean i think there's for sure a
hierarchy of symbolism in scripture i
think that
the you know that genesis like you said
exodus
um
the the story versions the story aspects
are very
are more important but they're not
there's not less symbolism
there's a lot of symbolism in paul's
epistles
just people for some reason they just
struggled to
they struggle to
i think that the more and more people
now are more of uh are more conscious of
what paul is actually talking about i
think that
it's becoming clear and clear that he's
he's laying it out for you i mean
saint paul when he talks about the man
is the head and the woman is the body
and then he talks about these
principalities and the thrones and and
how christ has is is going up you know
the principalities and subjugating all
these levels of reality you know into
himself and all of this stuff that paul
talks about i mean my goodness like
that's
it's amazing you know but i think that
i think it's the best way to understand
is that for sure let's say the gospels
let's say genesis
exodus and the gospels are like the
really
they're the they're the keys that say to
the rest and so you need those in order
to be able to then go into
more the let's say the explanations or
the details that you find in other
in other books but um
yeah
all right so ex perez says in your
episodes with andrew gould you mentioned
that orthodoxy is related to piracy
i didn't say that andrew gould said that
i was wondering if you could expand more
on that as i'm having trouble
understanding that what that could be i
don't know what andrew means by that i
been thinking about it for well i guess
i should have him on again i kept i said
i would and then some reason life just
got kind of got away with us
but i don't know why andrew says it's
related to pirates
i was really surprised that he was
saying that so i i it probably has
something to do with
with a kind of embodied
aesthetic practice maybe like especially
pirates like the ones that appear in
stories like they have a
they have a kind of uh
excessive
aesthetic
that is that kind of overflows and i
don't know if that's what he means i
don't know
i don't know andrew if you ever see this
i mean we should talk again on uh on the
on on on the channel all right so let's
see
so in the chat i'm seeing
brandon burns says jonathan are you a
tool fan if so any thoughts the symbols
of the album pure inoculum i'm not a
tool fan
a lot of people have kind of pointed me
to the tool and said they have really
complex music and super i just struggle
it's too it's just too heavy for me it's
it's hard to listen to i really like
melody and so i struggle
with music that isn't uh
that isn't um
that doesn't have good melody melodies
so a popper theologian asks is anything
meaningless
um and so i would say
let me answer it this way so no
because meaninglessness is the the place
where things
cease being things
so things are always meaningful but
there is a
place at the edge of things
where things break down and that's where
you can experience levels of
meaninglessness but obviously
ultimate meaninglessness or just pure
chaos is not a thing it's it's under
things it's
it's a field right it's a field of
possibility or a field of chaos um so
hopefully that makes sense
um so nathan hart says hi jonathan what
do you make of recent attempts to
divorce authors from the myths they
created of course there's been a
concerted attempt to disassociate
rowling from harry potter because of her
statements but i've also noticed an
increased push to divorce token
particularly catholic catholicism
traditionalism from lord of the rings
possibly drummed up by the new amazon
series yeah thank you if you're
feeling nice perhaps you can comment on
the symbolism of the spamming of russian
translation of jr's code of the trailer
yeah i saw that it's like it's just like
just the same comment about how you know
evil cannot create anything new but can
only distort or whatever that that uh
that comment is
um
i mean i think it's it's not it's not
not so much to dissociate the authors
but i think it's mostly to capture
there's a desire to capture all these
intellectual properties by you know the
new religion and that's definitely what
seems to be happening with toki and i'm
really disappointed at what i kind of
like
for sure i had a similar reaction to a
lot of people like what is going on in
this in this trailer like what is what
are they trying to to prove and i'm kind
of sad because
the the lady who did the costumes which
look awesome and the rings who designed
the rings and designed the costumes is
actually the her name is heather
pollington and she is the one who
did all my new branding i mean she's an
amazing artist she's just astounding and
so
and so i i was gonna i'm probably gonna
have her on the channel to talk about
some of her lord of the rings designs in
uh in the next few months
but uh but like you said it's just weird
to watch this like desire to capture
you know and it has to do with my idea
of parasitic storytelling that i
mentioned in my um
in my um
in one of my videos you know
that that's what's going on it's going
on everywhere right the desire to kind
of capture these stories and
and um
and control them for the new religion so
all right alexander
i was wondering if you could speak on
the catholicism the catholic symbolism
of the pelican and its younglings yes
where that symbol originated and how it
found significance on altars tabernacles
all over the world this particular
striking image as we enter the lenten
season what do you don't you think so
the uh the image that he's that
alexander is referring to is an image of
a a uh
of a pelican
that is feeding its children with its
own blood
and so this was like kind of like a
legend that existed or
because when you look at a pelican you
see the pelican
pelicans kind of
rub their
their beaks and their chest and so i
think like it it brought about a kind of
vision of the pelican that the pelican
was actually
let's say piercing itself and then
feeding itself feeding its its young
ones with its own blood and so it
obviously became an image of
self-sacrifice an image of communion
and that's why it was so prominent in in
early churches
you know and it's still useful today
even though even though you know it's
not
technically at least the way we
understand the word it's not technically
accurate anymore
i think um
i think it's still useful because it can
help you and it's still an image of
self-sacrifice if you kind of understand
the story that goes around it
the idea of giving yourself to to to
others
lisa says you y'all see the two
liturgical fans at the back don't freak
out but they look like two creepy eyes
[Laughter]
yeah that's my that those are my
liturgical fans i'm almost done with
them
i have to finish them i have to i have
to finish them but uh yeah they're
almost done
um
let's see what else
someone asks i feel like you used to
listen to punk music back in your youth
any nostalgic favorites and so
uh sure you know i l i started listening
to punk when i was like 13 i guess and
then
it was mostly like anybody that grew up
in the 90s is just the the bands that
were when i was when you're 13 and
you're not super
i mean you're still really young like i
like the violent femmes
and uh the dead milkman because it was
so funny and you're 13 and it's so
absurd and so those were the bands that
i liked when i was super young and then
later i really like the pixies a lot i
think that was the first concert i ever
went to see where the pixies
and um
and then moved out of punk and more into
kind of just the kind of alternative
stuff that became popular later in like
the
in the let's say in the mid 90s and so
so we were we were really into the red
hot chili peppers you know back in the
like
late 80s when they were just crazy and
super vulgar um so anyways i don't
necessarily recommend that although i do
think that like i do think that the song
the the song californication for example
that album
it's almost like it's like a liturgy for
the end of the world i mean it's if you
want to understand kind of end of the
world symbolism they just get it so
right and i think and they're they're
they're morons those guys i mean they're
all they're not very smart but i think
they're just they just had this
intuition about what california is and
when i talk about california's the end
of the world it's because it is and and
the red hot chili peppers get it right
they really get the symbolism right
about uh
about california and what it represents
and also kind of what they are as these
kind of chaotic nihilistic
crazy jester figures you know that that
are embodying that at the time
so um
yeah
all right so alexander another alexander
is there any symbolic connection between
saint christopher and christopher
columbus both sought to serve the most
powerful principality both across large
bodies of water that resulted in an
epoch making transformation
more personally for saint christopher
international for columbus
and the ship that carried columbus was
named the was named after mary santa
maria what do you think yeah definitely
there's definitely
christopher columbus is definitely a
symbolism happens moment you know where
you could say
despite himself
right so despite himself he end up let's
say connecting uh the west
with
with uh christianity you know and uh and
so it's interesting the idea of carrying
the dove you know across the ocean
into uh into the into the americas
um
and so but it's also like the beginning
of a new world right it's
the effect of change the amount of
change that christopher columbus brought
about or the colombian exchange is so
dramatic i mean it
people don't realize how dramatic the
transformation that happened at that
time is you know
so much of the food you eat for example
that you know
didn't exist before the colombian
exchange
like chocolate like
tomatoes you know there's so many
examples of food that we just totally
take for granted tobacco all these
things there's so much that kind of
that appeared at the time it was a
really it was like a bodily
transformation that happened in the
world with that connection and so um so
i definitely think that there is a
connection between the two
all right so kevin patterson in our
modern materials culture raw power
wealth and force
attract or worship just like in ancient
pagan cultures where their gods promise
them such power making materialist
worship the default for humans am i
right then in thinking that christianity
is actually quite radical and unique for
positing an afterlife directly connected
to
abstaining from material pleasures
does christianity
posit an afterlife that is based on
abstaining from material producers i
don't think so
um
so there are definitely
so let's let's kind of break that down
let's let's break that down so
there are definitely cultures which have
an ascetic quality to them except
besides uh besides um christianity and
so
buddhism
some ethics of
of hinduism
um and what is the other one i forget
the one where they don't even kill
insects
why is my brain sometimes just seizes up
on me um and so there are others
but i think that christianity it's
important to understand that
christianity doesn't and the afterlife
isn't connected to abstaining from
material pleasures but it's rather of
not being a slave to material pleasures
because
because the the problem is in the
material pleasures the problem is that
we are so
easily duped and seduced by them
and that we tend to act
towards them and so
and so asceticism is there to kind of
remove our slavery from
these material pleasures and be able to
focus higher but abstaining from
material pleasures is definitely not
going to get you into any
particular state on its own
it's just a way to be able to redirect
your your worship and your attention to
the proper
in the proper reorganize things in their
proper order you could say um
and so so yeah so i would say
i would say that it's probably better to
kind of understand it that way than to
understand it as a
yeah
all right
and so garrett whitner says hi john
forgive me for being so dim on this
i'm still trying to understand the
pattern of the ascent
ascending a mountain as with modis at
sinai
i can see the pattern itself but i'm
still cloudy on what it means or its
applicability
i notice recently when jesus praise and
gets gets m a in matthew 26 36 first he
leaves all the disciples but peter james
and john then he leaves even then then
comes back to them and finds them
sleeping yeah
how does this apply to human life
all i can see is that those who struggle
for virtue and succeed find that most
other people fall away
that doesn't seem deep or interesting
enough for such essential patterns
um
all right so
so there's a you can understand it this
way there's a there's an exchange that
happens between
that which is below and that which is
above
and so when you go up the mountain you
you kind of have to
be able to
abstract
that the multiplicity right if you
wanted if you want to
i'm trying to apply to everyday life for
you okay so this this is obviously has a
deeper kind of it does have a personal
meaning and a spiritual meaning the way
that it's described but you can
understand it that
if you want to if you want to uh
you've got let's say you've got a bunch
of of things
uh and you want to figure out how they
connect together
so you have to be able to move your get
your eyes away from the particulars you
kind of have to remove your eyes from
the particulars let's say you're you're
in uh you're in a team and everybody's
doing all a bunch of crazy stuff and
everybody's doing all these things and
you're like what is happening like what
why why we need to figure out what our
team is doing like what our purpose is
and how that organizes everything else
and so you have to
stop focusing on all the details because
you get lost in the details you get lost
at all the multiplicity so you kind of
have to
bring that down and there's a hierarchy
of that right so there's like all the
detailed details and then there's maybe
higher
aspects of what you're doing in the team
but you also have to kind of remove that
in order to find let's say the one thing
the one reason why everybody's doing
what they're doing okay and so
you can understand that when people
forget that purpose
they do something like fall asleep
or
they
worship idols right so think about it a
a team that's building something and
then people get caught up in the little
thing they're doing then they start
fighting with the other members of the
team because it's like here's trying to
stop us from doing the thing we're doing
and then it's like no it's your fault
and everybody's fighting because
because everybody's so focused on their
little task they don't see the big
picture
right and so
that's idolatry or it's there's also
like a sense of they just falling asleep
like why am i doing this why am i doing
this thing it's pointless i'm just gonna
sit in my office and i'm gonna go on
facebook because who cares i don't even
know what the purpose of what i'm doing
is and so all these people in the team
they can just become kind of
just drop and stop even really acting
together because they don't understand
what they're doing and so the person the
leader goes up finds the purpose of the
meaning finds the purpose of what
they're doing
and then that person
comes back down the mountain
and says wake up
remember the purpose
remember the attention so christ says
i'm going up to pray i'm going up to the
highest thing i'm going to i'm going up
to worship god
and i want you to
to to participate in this i want you to
remember the highest thing don't forget
it
and so they forget and they fall asleep
they forget and they worship idols like
in the story of moses
so christ has to come back down
and has to wake them up
and that implies uh
you know
this idea of saying to wake up or it
also implies a a judgment you could say
where you
when moses comes back down
and he finds the people worshiping the
golden the the the golden calf
there is some judgment that's going to
happen
that is that some people are gonna get
cut off and some activities are gonna
get cut off so you can see the same with
the team it's like you have this team
doing a bunch of stuff you don't know
what's going on and so the leader goes
up or someone goes up
finds the purpose of what this team is
for then comes back down first of all
says wake up this is what we're doing
and then looks at what everybody's doing
and then decides well you know what this
is useless
out this
is not to
pointing to the higher thing this needs
to go this person
doesn't have the skills needed to be
part of this team they need to go
and then maybe you're actually going to
gather in more things that are more
aligned with what you're with what
you're doing so that's how it applies to
everyday life because it's basically the
pattern of
of of of attention itself and the
pattern of what we do in the world so
yeah hope that makes sense
all right
all right so andrew blank says
i was reading an article on an orthodox
blog about suffering and death
the article refers to death as
intrinsically meaningless
and how even the cross reveals this as
someone who's observed the death of my
father and now stepfather cliche is like
there's a there's a purpose reason for
it seem misapplied how do you think
about suffering death and its meaning or
inherent lack of and how does it differ
from a protestant view
so i kind of understand
what this person is saying when they're
saying that that death is
meaningless in the sense that you know
when i you ask someone ask me if
something is meaningless and i said
what's meaningless is when it's the edge
of a thing the end the the place where
the thing breaks down
is that's what meaningless is and so
there's a sense in which death
is related to that
because it is the place where your body
breaks down is the place where the
spirit and the body gets separated where
things fall apart and so it is
meaninglessness
manifesting itself in the world
now
it's not the idea that you necessarily
have to find the purpose
or the reason for it
but there's there is something
about death
that
there is something about death which
can be can be transformed into glory
that the breakdown which happens
can actually become a kind of
of of glory i don't know how to say it
and that's what you see on the cross
and that's what you see in a lot of the
imagery related to the cross
where
meaninglessness becomes something like
that which is outside of meaning or that
which
transcends meaning
or
the place where meaning breaks down
there's a place where meaning breaks
down below but there's also a place
where meaning kind of breaks down above
and that's the crown or that's the crown
of thorns that's the this kind of
explosion into something higher and so i
think that
that's ultimately what death
can become now
it's not always that and uh
but i think that that's what martyrdom
is for sure and and
and i think that there's a
a sense in which
you know if you look at the idea of
relics that seems to have something to
do with that right where it's like the
death and then the cutting up of an
actual human body
becomes something like the
the crown the jewel of
and the the central holy place of uh of
a of a church or
so
that's how i see it you know but it's
hard to talk about this stuff talking
about death man
all right so roger sterling asks hi
jonathan my question is regarding the
cringe phenomena
seems triggered by clumsy attempts at
things like dancing singing telling
jokes or sexual or sexual seduction
why is that activities which are
potentially transcendent when done well
are so humiliating when done poorly i
mean it has to do with sin like sin in
the technical sense not necessarily in
the moral sense but it has to do with
something like the reaction of watching
somebody miss the mark you know
like it's painful it's like it's it's
it's humanly painful to watch someone
miss
to miss the mark and try really hard but
miss it or sometimes think they hid it
but totally
missed it you know and so it's like it's
embarrassing to see someone sin it's
like you're just like you're seeing
their nakedness you know in the biblical
sense where you
they're exposed like their weakness
their
the place where heaven and earth doesn't
match is like exposed to you
and your and it's like
it's painful to watch
um yeah
yes norman roder says jainism yes that's
what i was referring to before in terms
of the the the
let's say a religion that is extremely
about uh self-denial and
and fasting like extreme fasting and
stuff
um and refusing earthly pleasures and
you know not not killing anything
so
all right manuel
montiel asks can idolatry be further
understood as a sort of abandonment
of the logos and movement towards
non-being and if this is the case when
everything that we do that isn't
directed towards god be considered
idolatrous even the most trivial things
the image of the ghost in c.s lewis the
great divorce keeps playing over in my
head when i think about this
so it's it's it's just about hierarchy
it really is just about hierarchy that
is
all things are good in their place they
become idolatrous when they're not in
their right place but they are
in the wrong
when you place them in the wrong
position in the hierarchy when you give
them
more attention than they should that
they should have
that's when they become idolatrous so
so yeah
so things can be indirectly directed
towards god when they are in their
proper place you know and when they're
also done with the in the spirit of
gratitude you could say
towards god and so i think that's the
best way to understand that
all right so
would god exist so david cookson in the
chat as would god exist without their
being conscious beings
and uh i would say that that's a just a
bad question i don't know what to tell
you it's like
that's not how it is
god you know god exists and conscious
beings exist
and we can see god through
through consciousness
and so so it's a it's one of those
questions which
is not i don't think you can actually
ask
because
i don't even know what it means like i
don't know what that question means it's
yeah so i hope that makes sense all
right annie crawford asked your recent
podcast on king david made me think of
hamlet who also finds himself to be the
true
true true hair in trouble with a false
king helmet also plays the gesture to
fool the trickster as he tries to deal
with the situation yeah yeah definitely
i never felt satisfied with the typical
explications of hamlet's character is he
a failed king david trying to navigate
the same space but unable to hold the
tension long enough to succeed yeah
that's a good insight you've got there
any insights on the symbolism of hamlets
hamlet are all welcome
and so
there's definitely something of what
you're saying going on in hamlet for
sure you know uh
but there's it's more like in hamlet
there's something like that's even more
corrupt about the situation which is
what makes hamlet such a tragic figure
which is
that not only is the king
you know the illegitimate
not only did the king kill his father
you know the king also was sleeping with
his mother
and they colluded you know to kill his
father and so
it's he's really in a bad situation if
you think about in terms of like normal
hierarchy and so
right so he's he's the one who's
supposed to become king but there's a
manner in which
he's stuck because he's going to succeed
something which is
illegitimate and and we also have to
remember that
that hamlet's father appears to him
and that is also what
leads hamlet in in terms of
trying to bring about some kind of of of
justice but
the story of hamlet is it has to do with
like the self-devouring that happens
when causality breaks apart you know
where it's like
his uncle
yeah i think his uncle right his uncle
is now his father
right and his mother is his aunt and and
then you know the
the man who's his father killed his real
father
and so it's as if causality is breaking
down and then that ends with
a kind of bloodbath where everybody dies
basically where it's like it just
collapses the system collapses because
in trying to
restore it
hamlet ends up
you know dying himself ends up and the
whole confusion of the swords and the
poison and all this stuff it's like it
just it just it just shows you how all
of this is bringing about like such a
confusion and causality then in the end
everybody just
just it's over right it just ends the
the line you could say
devolves into total chaos
all right so nate barker says hey
jonathan what do you say to someone who
is struggling with their faith due to
the violence in the old testament that
god seemingly commands i canaanite
conquest
and those who say god commands genocide
et cetera
and so
i understand it's definitely a tough one
but
i think you really really do have to
understand that the church fathers
really
took that symbolism and then tried to
apply it to yourself
and so
you know all of a sudden then the the
let's say the conquest that you see in
the psalms and this deliver me from my
enemies and and you know conquer my
enemies ends up being now the internal
battle with passions and thoughts you
know and even the most horrible
statement you know that statement of
like we'll dash their children on the
rocks which is like just a horrible
statement there's a sense in which the
church fathers talk about like
the children of your enemies if you read
saint gregory he does the work for it
for us in bringing all that together the
children of your enemies is something
like these thoughts like all the little
thoughts that that come in your mind
and that come from the outside and try
to kind of kind of creep up on you and
so you have to stop them before they
grow into it into adults or else they're
going to take over and so the analogy is
perfect like the analogy is perfect in
the sense that
like if you were at war with like uh uh
if you were at war with like uh another
nation and then you
you're not careful with how you manage
their children then they're gonna grow
up and then they're gonna come and
attack you right i mean it's just very
simple tribal symbolism and so there's
something obviously which is kind of
horrendous about that
but there's there's something which is
also
manifest some aspect of reality and so
the way the church father is going to
bring that into the person and then
apply it at that level which is the
proper level
to to apply it then then i think it it
helps to
to reconcile that but uh but i
understand because it's uh
yeah
all right so mid
o hamad ali says while jonathan what is
the symbolism of suicide
um
and so i mean the symbolism of suicide
is uh
is the symbolism of
it's the symbolism of of circular
causality you know
and so
it has to do with the snake eating its
tail it's like you
take a sword and you turn it back on you
and then you stick it in yourself um
and so
that's what suicide is it's just a
it's uh yeah it's a breakdown of normal
of normal causality and so
so that's why it's so dark in uh in at
least in traditional christianity that's
why suicide
is something out of which is difficult
to
get out of the consequences of right
because you're basically
you're ending yourself
in this weird breakdown of causality and
so it's uh
yeah so it's not a great uh
it's not it's not the best thing for
it's not the best thing for moving over
like crossing over you could say
all right so gr says how do you respond
to four backs accusation of christianity
worshiping the representation over the
represented the copy over the original i
was taken back upon learning this as i
agree on the problem of the map taking
over the territory but i see
it as scientists and materialism and
protestantism being the main offenders
while christ's incarnation being the
solution is in the case of the accuser
accusing others of its own misdeeds
thank you
and
so you're like worshiping the
representation in the sense of christ
over god is that what i'm getting here
because
it's obvious in christianity that we
worship
god through christ and not
we don't worship christ on his own
you know we worship christ
we worship christ
as he is the divine logos and and is the
one that manifests god to us and so it
really is more
of
it really is more of kind of
solving the problem of representation
and represented and
creating a theory about reality in which
the the represented can participate in
the re the representation can
participate in the represented that is
that
the world lays itself out organically
and naturally out of the one into the
many and that this is not a scandal it's
not something which is which cannot be
resolved that it can be resolved
um but that it's ultimately all if they
turn towards the father you could say
and i think that at least in orthodox
christianity that's pretty clear
um so
yeah
so no way palacios asked what is the
symbolism of the illness of assad
and uzi and
uzia
and hezekiah kings of judah
two chronicles it says that assad got
sick in his feet
jehoram got sick in his bowels
uzziah got leprosy on his forehead and
hezekiah got sick to death
i don't know
i never thought about this at all
i mean it's interesting
at least the way you say it i'd have to
reread it but it's interesting because
there's definitely like uh there's
definitely like a moving up where it's
like if you're just sick in your feet
it's not uh
it's not that dangerous
uh
whereas if you're sick in your bowels
you know it's more it's higher up and
it's more dangerous
if you get leprosy on your forehead then
it affects your identity you know
it affects the way people see you and
the way you interact with others like
the others can be hidden and you can
have your your feet
sick or your bowel sick and nobody would
know it's like a hidden thing but then
when it's on your forehead then
everybody sees and then obviously
hezekiah
got sick to his old being or his little
being collapsed before the sickness and
so he died and so there's like higher
there's a weird hierarchy of death there
that's kind of interesting
to think about
all right drew mcmahon asks hi jonathan
can you explain the symbols of moses
leading the israelites for 40 years but
at the very end himself not making it
into the promised land thank you
ultimately i really do think that it has
something to do with the transfer from
one world to the other you can really
see that
it seemed like for a world to end and
then another world to begin there has to
be some aspect of the world before which
goes up
into heaven
and that is what kind of brings about
the end of the world you could say but
it also is what
makes it possible for the next world to
start
um i mentioned this before like so it's
related to the idea of enoch going up
before the flood and then moses going up
before the entry into israel
and then you also have
elijah going up you know at the end of
the
the
of the northern kingdom
um
and then christ going up before the holy
spirit comes down
et cetera et cetera and so that seems to
be and it also seems to be i think i
mentioned this before which is that i
always kind of really i was never a big
fan of the idea of the um
of the rapture you know like kind of the
way that evangelicals talk about the
rapture and then matsir kind of
matzier really uh
caught me and said you know the rapture
is just another version of that
symbolism that's there from the
beginning it's like before the end of
the world some aspect of the world has
to go up and so i don't know exactly
what that means in terms of practice but
yeah it's just interesting to see that
it's the basically the same pattern as
what you see
um and it's interesting because moses in
scripture it's it says it basically
suggests that he dies but then later in
the in in the new testament it says that
his body was taken up by say michael so
there's something about bodily ascension
uh that that that is part of this
transfer you know that's why you see uh
elijah go up and and enoch
so um
stuff and christ to go up bodily
all right sean desmond says in order to
construct the tar babel the people use
baked brick and slime instead of stone
and mortar
genesis 11
3.
this can be juxtaposed with uncut stones
used to build
the altar according to god's command
what's up with that is it slime or is it
is it pitch i think it's pitch
um
that's my understanding is that it's
that it's something
that it's uh it's pitch so it's like the
the darks the dark sticky stuff we
talked about oil this like dark sticky
stuff which is kind of at the bottom of
the world and so you have the stones
then in between the stones you have this
this like stuff that represents the
bottom of reality that connects the
stones together the sticky the sticky
pitch
um and so i think that that's the that's
mostly what's
important and then the big brick
instead of stones
um
has to do with civilization itself right
the the the baked earth and the this
idea of using
technology to create
the structure of your thing and then
adding the gooey the gooey pitch like
this residue stuff this dark sticky
stuff on this on the sides and that's my
that's my kind of understanding with
that of that
um
so scotty torp asked did jesus laugh
and i say that laughing how is laughter
related to transgression and so there's
a tradition
saint john chrysostom says jesus didn't
laugh
and i think that the reason why he says
that is that it has something to do with
the idea that laughing is a form of
transgression not necessarily moral but
transgression in the sense that it is
it is loss of control of yourself that's
what laughing is
and
most of the time laughing is something
that
happens to you right you see something
that you did that you didn't expect and
it's a reaction to what you see you read
something and it's a reaction to what
you you read and so
i think that that's the
that's the sense and that christ is not
doesn't have unwield reaction that his
engagement in the world is always full
and always
complete you could say
um and so that i think is why there's
that tradition but
i think we have to be careful not to
take it
too extreme um because i do think that
laughter does have a
a kind of
a function you could say in the world um
and uh and that it has to do with
something like uh
yeah it has to do with that sabbath it
has to do with something with the end
like the the moment
when when you know and it also has to do
with a kind of
a reception of what's happening in a way
that and also there's a power in
laughter i think especially at the end
of you know laughing at something if you
look at the way laughter is used in
scripture for example when elijah laughs
at the illegitimate illegitimate
prophets there's a power in that which
is really uh
um and so you could see that christ
maybe you could say christ didn't laugh
but christ for sure mocked like you can
see christ mocking the uh
the uh the
um the phyllis not the philistines the
pharisees
all right i'm getting tired guys
um especially with my back i told you my
back went out a few days ago and it's
still kind of
it's still kind of going
um all right so norm grenade says last
month you spoke about the idea of the
remnant after the kingdom split acting
as that spark of renewal when the time
was right are we in an age of biblical
exile in the modern world and as
christians are we remnants of the
kingdom
if so what is our role and how best do
we navigate our way through the
landscape of exile both richly and
physically in the world
and so
i would say
watch my video on king david
in terms of
you know
how to avoid the pharaoh right you know
what is it uh
moses gets put in a basket with pitch
and then on the water and then you know
going on the water is the way to avoid
the pharaoh
uh it's interesting because in the story
of moses you see that there's like a
voluntary desire
to put moses in the water
in order
in order to avoid the tyranny of the
pharaoh whereas in the flood story it's
almost like a natural posses procession
of the story but in moses it's like
you know you you're in this basket with
pitch
and then you are floating on the water
and so
sorry i keep wanting to sneeze
so i think that that's that's something
to to think about you know i watch our
video on david and and see
how we
can avoid
the tyranny
in a moment of um
you know in a moment where it's it's
very present and and very strong
so i would say yes we are in a way in a
world of exile more and more it's gonna
be more and more true as we go and it's
gonna get worse that's for sure so
yeah we have to start thinking like a
remnant
so eb what's the deal with all the kings
fighting
in genesis 14 right before melchizedek
appears
um
so what's the deal with all the kings
fighting i mean it you could understand
it as a moment when everything is ever
all these things are falling apart
and then melchizedek appears and so
melchizedek
is is very important to understand
melchizedek is a very strange figure
because melchizedek is both a king
and a priest
which is not something which is normal
you usually don't have figures that are
both a king and a priest at the same
time and so melchizedek seems to
represent something which
is
kind of not in the world or is really
kind of coming out from above and then
kind of
participates in reestablishing a new
order by offering
the the the sacrifice of bread and wine
and
so and so he's a very fascinating figure
there aren't that many figures that are
both uh priests and kings at the same
time you see that of course christ is
obviously that is both a priest and a
king at the same time
um and that's why it says that you know
like in the book of hebrews that
melchizedek is a it's like is a king
that has no generation that is that is
not that is
you know that doesn't have
a generation he's the first he's kind of
like he represents this first so it's
hard to square that you see that in
different books like book of jubilees
they try to square it like melchizedek
is one of noah's sons that come from
before the flood or the character from
before the flood in order to kind of say
that he transcends the whole thing like
the whole system he he precedes
everything
um
and so that's what that's what and
melchizedek appearing
and then kind of blessing
uh
abraham is something like you know the
let's say the
the highest point in the world is is
giving its blessing to abraham it's
almost like christ is blessing abraham
in that story in a certain manner not
directly but let's say
story ways in story story form
um
so something which is above the king and
the priest is coming down
to
to give transfer authority to abraham
all right so wavering radiant can you
explain what it means for art or
anything for that matter to be
liturgical
so it's i mean it's
strictly you could say that the there's
liturgical art which is something which
is dedicated let's say an object of
of of life which is dedicated to god and
therefore
finds its highest purpose
in being dedicated to god and serving
its function but within the worship
of the highest and so you know like a
whatever object is used in the in the
liturgy whatever music whatever building
all of this is kind of like the summit
of reality where the the art is
dedicated to god and manifest its
highest aspect
um
so at a lower level you could understand
it liturgical in the sense of just
participative so i've talked about this
several times the difference between art
which is
participative and art which is just
let's say something like entertainment
or something that just like uh
passive passive entertainment
all right so joe kelly good says has
anyone done an audio book version of
matches book i'd love to be able to
listen to it no i don't think that's
going to happen just because matthew's
book is so much
i mean more than let's say the most of
what you get from matthew's book is from
the diagrams not from the text the text
are important but it's like the real
insights come from the diagram so i
don't see how he would it would be weird
to have it as an audio book
all right then db says our religious
rituals and organized religion in
general including christianity another
kind of garment of skin
and the answer is is yeah to a certain
extent
um
but it's also a garment of skin which
can be kind of transformed into a
garment of glory but it definitely is a
garment of skin it's interesting like
you if you read genesis you'll see
that
there's the fall and then people kind of
leave the garden and move away from the
garden and then the descendants of cane
start to create things and technology
and stuff and then it says
like from that time
is when people started to call upon the
name of the lord and you think like wow
interesting but then you realize that
let's say the religious forms and the
rituals and the need to call upon the
name of the lord means that you also
have a certain distance from that um and
so i think that's and so a lot of the
the symbolism of the
of religious rituals have to do with
that it's like a memory we remember
that which is far away and so we we
engage in these patterns
in order to embody and remember that
which transcends it um
but then ultimately there's a sense in
which
we talked about this idea of like
representing the represent you know
let's say worshiping the representation
or the represented
earlier when talking about uh
i think it was far back um
there's a there's a sense in which
there's a sense in which in christianity
it kind of all comes together and so
that's why communion is something like
perfect memory community is something
like the place
of
of true memory where memory becomes
participates fully in the thing that it
remembers
and so
and so that's what christianity does to
that and so that's really when
something like the garments of skin are
transformed into
back into their earlier
function which are the garments of glory
so chandler turner says an often
repeated phrase these days is believe
science
is this a symbolism happens moment where
individuals who surely believe in the
objective nature of science are refining
that trust is fundamental to
empiricism
no what they're doing is they're hiding
their story behind science is what
they're doing because when they're
saying believe science what they really
mean is
do what i would do what i'm saying and
what i'm saying is believing science
right so
science is not prescriptive in any way
it doesn't prescribe anything and and so
when people say something like follow
the science or believe science
it's like what they're saying is
so you saw it i didn't drink kobe it was
it was the most it was the most
egregious it was so egregious
you know everybody who was saying their
thing and you still i'm still hearing it
now because i was forced because of all
the craziness in canada to listen to
parliamentary debates which which i
never do because it's so unbearable but
you're forced to and you still people
say things like two people sitting
across the aisle saying
will you follow the science and do what
i'm saying right i'm the one who's
following the science my political
position is the one that's following the
science and it's just so
embarrassing because you because you
can't follow science and
yeah
all right stephen bishop i've been told
that soldiers saints should be depicted
in civilian clothes when painted on the
arkansas rather than in their armor and
weapons
is this because the violent nature of
the soldiers somewhat monstrous and
marginal therefore cannot be to go to
the center at the sanctuary as if
soldier saints was removing a garment of
skin as he gets close to god i guess i
mean i don't know why
i i've never seen that especially
because saint michael is often
represented in an armor often
represented wearing an armor on the
iconic sasses so
i know it's just weird i never i've
never seen that tradition but that's
probably what people would say that's
probably the reason why they would say
that but uh
i think it's weird because
there are plenty of images of saint
michael especially
on aiken assassins wearing armors
all right nicola alexik alexi ask in
some of the psalms we hear prayers for
god to punish the enemies of the
faithful in very descriptive ways
how would you read this today i feel
very easy reading these verses
especially when i imagine my enemies of
today that are politically elite and
what i would want them to go through as
a consequence of their action i don't
want to be resentful but these verses
don't help they rather magnify my
problem and so i mentioned this before
which is that for sure the church
fathers the way they interpret the
psalms is that it's an inner battle and
so the enemies my enemies are not
other people but they are my thoughts my
passions there are the desires that kind
of creep up on me you know um that's
what my enemies are when you read the
psalms and so it's taking let's say the
world of combat and the fighting
uh
and then kind of bringing it in
bringing it inside
you know and so that's usually what the
that's usually what the um the psalms
are talking about but i
i think that it's i think that
i think it's not completely illegitimate
in a moment let's say where a country is
being attacked from the outside by
barbarians like let's say you know the
mongols are at the gates of the city um
i do think that it's appropriate to
re-engage these psalms in a more
in a more kind of city in a
at the city level or at the at the
higher level
i think that that's okay
um
i think we have to be careful with our
own personal enemies because let's say
the enemy of a city and people attacking
a city is different from my personal
enemy in the sense of someone that
annoys me or someone that has done me
wrong
but i think it is definitely possible to
ask god to deliver us from our enemies
when we are being
attacked by
um
you know by by
foreign armies that are coming in to to
attack you so i think that's totally
fine
all right and so
so a popper so i'm back in i'll do just
maybe a few in the chat here so a popper
theologian asks what is the role place
of chance in a meaningful world and so
yeah the world place of chances that is
the place where causality breaks down
it's the place where meaning kind of
falls apart at the end and at the end of
the day that's why that's why you play
games of chance at the end of the day
matthew talks about this quite well in
his book about you know this the imagery
of the remainder and the imagery of the
sabbath and the imagery of the end where
that's where things like chants come
about and you know where causality
breaks down that's what chance is it's
like it's kind of like there's no
there's no clear causality which is
explaining to me why this is happening
it seems random seems to not participate
in meaning
um
and that's definitely part of the big
like big the big system
um
so chris bookhold says jordan calls it
slime in the biblical series oh
interesting
so i don't know i'm pretty sure it's
pitch
because it
i don't know i may be wrong but i think
that it's the same word that's used to
describe what they put in the ark
am i wrong
and what's put in the uh the uh the
basket of moses so
i think i'm right but i might be wrong
i have to check it out check it i'll
chat to check on it when i'm done with
this and
and uh and see if i'm wrong or right so
so kh asks hello jonathan what is the
symbolism of being below an oak tree it
often seems to mark the limit of
and mediate what is pagan
is there a lesson in there for us in the
west thank you for your time i'm not
sure what you mean below an oak tree
imagine what you mean
never thought about that
so
all right guys
i think we're done
so i was able to keep it under two hours
this time
and so uh so thanks everybody for your
attention and uh as usual thanks for
your support i really appreciate it i'm
finally ramping back up the website you
know i got really discouraged because
everything kind of fell apart in terms
of redesigning the website and i
presented to you guys with the for those
that are supporting my patreon i put up
a video that shows the the new branding
which is which is going and now the
reprogramming of the website is now
officially started and so i'm pretty
happy i wanted to also wait until some
point i was like okay i need to wait
until the end of god's dog before i do
the website but now we're going in full
force
and uh and it seems like pretty sure
like it's
anyways it seems pretty sure that i'm
going to write a book in uh this year
and that it might actually
um like it might be a popular
fiction book and so i'm kind of talking
with a bunch of people about that and
there's some exciting things on the
horizon if it can it can come to
together so
so thanks everybody for your attention
thanks for showing up and uh and i will
see you see you next month bye bye
everybody